cuando comencé a pensar en este vídeo me
di cuenta de que el asma iba a ser un
tema muy difícil de tratar sobre todo
porque hay muchas personas que lo tienen
y muchas personas saben al menos un
poquito de lo que es el asma y podría
ser bastante complicado digamos llegar
al fondo de lo que realmente es el asma
así que para hacer esto vamos a iniciar
desde el comienzo vamos a hablar de los
pulmones y cómo es que se ven y cómo es
que o qué es lo que hacen esencialmente
así que aquí tenemos nuestra nuestra
tráquea digamos aquí tenemos la tráquea
que se ramifica en dos grandes bronquios
verdad tenemos estos dos grandes
bronquios el bronquio de la izquierda y
el bronquio de la derecha y estas son
digamos las principales ramas de los
pulmones y de aquí estas dos ramas se
siguen justamente ramificando
distintas otras ramas okay digamos más o
menos de esa forma y por supuesto esto
se ramifica como si fuera un árbol
verdad es exactamente como la misma idea
que hay en los árboles y el digamos hay
muchísimos niveles verdad aquí solo voy
a pintar digamos algunos niveles verdad
pero esto se sigue dividiendo y se sigue
ramificando muchas veces y creo que con
esto ya tienes la idea verdad cuando
inhalamos digamos funcionamos como una
especie de aspiradora verdad cuando
inhalamos lo que obtenemos al inhalar es
moléculas de oxígeno o2 verdad son dos
átomos de oxígeno mientras que cuando
exhalamos liberamos moléculas de dióxido
de carbono cuya fórmula química es co2
es decir un átomo de carbono y dos de
oxígeno
ahora bien el asma está clasificado como
una enfermedad obstructiva de la cuando
el aire se bloquea al salir verdad por
eso vamos a hablar un poquito de eso más
adelante por ahora
vamos a fijarnos en este conjunto de
tubos que forman digamos las vías aéreas
verdad que es como se le conoce también
se le conoce como vías respiratorias
entonces en cualquier lugar de este de
estos tubos digamos si hacemos un corte
por aquí un corte de esta forma es lo
que conocemos nosotros como una sección
transversal digamos de este tubo lo que
vamos a ver es algo parecido a esto
tendremos aquí nuestro corte del tubo y
digamos esta es la pared exterior del
tubo y después tenemos como una apertura
aquí adentro tenemos una especie de
apertura aquí adentro que lo que se
encuentra digamos en medio lo conocemos
como lumen ok y el lumen esencialmente
es cualquier interior de un tubo de
hecho es en el lumen por donde el aire
atraviesa y justo en las paredes digamos
de estas vías aéreas tenemos tejido
conectivo por ejemplo podemos tener
a nulas y podemos tener muchos
muchísimos tipos de cosas en esta parte
de los tubos muy bien así que de lo que
quiero hablar ahorita es de digamos esta
capa de músculo suave que tenemos
alrededor verdad en la pared de nuestras
vías aéreas así que dado que es un
músculo en realidad tiene una fuerza
para cambiar la forma de lo que tiene
alrededor verdad así que en el caso del
asma que es lo que estamos trabajando en
este vídeo este músculo suave de hecho
puede apretar digamos mucho más esta vía
aérea así que para ver cómo es que se ve
déjenme dibujar esto de nuevo vamos a
hacer exactamente el mismo
círculo verdad nuevamente este es el
exterior de la pared verdad y cuando una
persona tiene que está presenciando un
ataque de asma en ese momento lo que
pasa es que las vías aéreas van a ser
mucho más pequeñas verdad
digamos no se pensemos lo de este tamaño
que es mucho más pequeño con respecto al
que habíamos pintado anteriormente
entonces el lumen es lo que va a ser más
pequeño verdad y en esencia lo que está
ocurriendo es que el músculo digamos de
alrededor está construyendo mucho más
esta vía aérea muy bien lo que está
haciendo es apretando esta vía aérea y
provoca que se reduzca mucho el tamaño
del lumen y lo que hace todavía peor la
circunstancia es que cuando nuestro
cuerpo está inflamado secreta fluidos
verdad así que el lumen el lumen que
tenemos aquí en realidad aunque en
principio se supone que debería estar
abierto y seco ahora tenemos además
fluido extra así que esta apertura de
por sí ya es pequeña y además está
digamos inundado con
y fluidos así que toda esta fe esta
imagen digamos contáis cómo se ve el
asma en nuestras vías aéreas ahora aquí
por supuesto sólo hemos mostrado un tubo
pero si hacemos ese mismo corte en todos
los demás tubos podemos imaginar que en
realidad este proceso está ocurriendo en
todos estos tubos que forman digamos
nuestra aspiradora verdad así que en
realidad el aire tiene muchos problemas
moviéndose de hecho si podemos imaginar
digamos como una especie de aspiradora
pintar como una especie de aspiradora y
por supuesto estas inspiradoras era como
de un modelo bastante primitivo verdad
pensemos que aquí tenemos nuestra
aspiradora verdad y esto tiene una
manguera principal esa manguera
principal podría corresponder a la
tráquea verdad ahora bien aquí tenemos
una capacidad de absorber aire verdad de
de tragar el aire con mucha fuerza tiene
una muy buena capacidad para tomar aire
pero a la hora de que el aire salga en
realidad este es un proceso pasivo
verdad no hay no hay una fuerza no hay
un motor que está empujando el aire
hacia afuera verdad así que aunque
tenemos una constricción aquí va a ser
por supuesto va a ser difícil succionar
aire hacia los pulmones pero al menos
hay un motor que se encuentra detrás de
todo esto verdad por supuesto cuando
pensamos el proceso contrario es decir a
la hora de liberar aire este proceso es
pasivo verdad y eso ocurre en los
pequeños tubos a 10 o por supuesto
cuando estamos en la situación en donde
tenemos un ataque de asma lo vuelve algo
difícil de realizar
es muy difícil exhalar cuando tenemos un
ataque de asma ahora primero hablemos de
las causas de este proceso porque
nuestras vías aéreas de repente se
cerrarían cómo se cierran en el caso del
asma por qué porque nuestro cuerpo
permitiría eso y sobre todo qué es lo
que lo detona y yo les prometo que cada
vez que hablemos de los pulmones lo
primero de lo que vamos a hablar es de
el del cigarro de fumar fumar es una de
las grandes causas que que puede detonar
el asma muy bien y por supuesto cuando
hablamos de fumar no significa
únicamente que seas una persona que
sostiene los cigarrillos y seas
directamente quien lo fuma sino puede
ser también por cuestiones de por
ejemplo cuando tenemos fumadores pasivos
que es el caso de los niños y tú te
preguntarás bueno y por qué esto es
cierto
por ejemplo cuando tenemos papás que
fuman en realidad aunque lo hagan en el
jardín
las partículas que se liberan a la hora
de fumar se quedan en la ropa y eso es
después entran a la casa a través de la
ropa muy bien así que aunque no fumemos
directamente podemos estar inhalando
estas partículas otra de las razones es
porque vivimos en un tiempo en donde
estamos muy cercanos a distintos tipos
de máquinas que contaminan el ambiente
verdad así que por ejemplo podríamos
pensar en un auto verdad que en las
grandes ciudades hay muchísimos autos
que estos a su vez al ser utilizados
liberan muchísimos contaminantes otra
razón puede ser que la gente digamos en
sus empleos está expuesto a cosas como
como asbestos u otro tipo de cosas que
pueden inhalar verdades se puede ser
otra razón que detone el asma y vamos a
seguir escribiendo mejor las cosas otra
de las causas es inhalar cierto tipo de
pinturas otra causa puede ser también y
este es es una causa muy triste porque
algunos tipos de alimentos pueden
provocar también que se dé un ataque de
asma por ejemplo
ser algún tipo de alergia o puede ser
alguna especie de sustancia que
encontremos en el vino o en la cerveza
otra otra causa que a mí se me hace muy
interesante es el caso de bueno un
medicamento que toman muchos adultos
para controlar los dolores de cabeza y
estamos hablando de la aspirina en
principio sabemos que nos ayuda a
combatir los dolores de cabeza pero se
ha visto que detona el 30 por ciento de
los casos en adultos que tienen asma y
otro caso u otra otro factor que detona
el asma es muy interesante y esto se da
principalmente en bebés que es el
reflujo gastrointestinal el reflujo
vamos a escribir lo que y lo que también
conocemos como agruras verdad aquí en la
cuestión es que el estómago digamos los
líquidos que se encuentran en el
estómago regresan hacia el esófago y
como los bebés son muy pequeños los
sistemas están muy cercanos
así que digamos los líquidos del
estómago pueden subir al esófago hacia
la tráquea y eso puede detonar asma así
que como puedes ver esto en realidad
alcanza muchísimos aspectos de la vida y
eso es probablemente por la cual muchas
personas tienen asma aunque es muy
distinto en cada una de ellas así que
vamos a regresar digamos a nuestra forma
de ver digamos de forma clínica en el
caso del asma verdad si vamos a escuchar
a una persona que está respirando y que
tiene asma verdad cómo sonaría bueno
déjenme dibujar un estetoscopio verdad
tenemos un estetoscopio y vamos a
escuchar a través del estetoscopio cómo
respira una persona ahora si
consideramos muy bien lo que hemos dicho
anteriormente aquí tenemos muchos
fluidos verdad en estas en estas vías
tenemos muchos fluidos verdad tenemos
muchos fluidos en toda la vía y estos
músculos suaves están
digamos encogiéndose y como ya hemos
dicho tenemos fluidos y moco verdad que
está siendo secretado en estos tubos
como parte de nuestra respuesta a la
inflamación verdad así que el aire y los
fluidos juntos que es lo que forman pues
esencialmente empiezan a formar burbujas
cierto burbujas que se rompen y se
vuelven a formar a la hora de tratar de
respirar cuando tenemos esta secreción
excesiva de fluidos entonces esto es lo
que nos va a definir cómo se escucha
a través de un estetoscopio
esencialmente se escucha un ruido o sea
un sonido agudo al cual nos referimos
como sibilancias muy bien sibilancias
son estos digamos sonidos agudos que son
muy característicos de las enfermedades
obstructivas como el asma aunque las
sibilancias básicamente suenan como un
pequeño silbato y esto se da a la hora
de inhalar y exhalar verdad a la hora de
exhalar es cuando podemos escuchar estos
sonidos agudos a través de
los pulmones muy bien ahora déjenme
dibujar una línea imaginaria voy a
dibujar una línea imaginaria y acá abajo
encontramos las vías aéreas pequeñas
verdad entonces las sibilancias en el
asma es una enfermedad de las vías
aéreas pequeñas que ocurre a la hora de
la exhalación muy bien estas sibilancias
ocurren a la hora de exhalar el aire muy
bien si nosotros descubrimos digamos
este ruido a la hora de la inspiración
digamos de la inspiración ok si
escuchamos este tipo de ruidos en la
inspiración eso generalmente está
causado por un cuerpo por un cuerpo
externo verdad o algún tipo de proceso
que hace que la parte digamos que
tenemos arriba esté encogida así que eso
en realidad no ocurre en el asma a menos
de que sea una situación severa
usualmente el asma obtenemos el aire
pero es a la hora de exhalar en donde
tenemos problemas y es donde podemos
escuchar las sibilancias ahora
vayamos a la siguiente parte en realidad
yo no tengo asma verdad y digamos no
creo que sea digamos el mejor juez para
para decir cómo es que se siente verdad
pero las personas que tienen asma
podemos imaginar que esta persona
digamos tiene problemas de asma ok
esta es una persona que tiene problemas
de asma y si imaginamos que tienen
problemas a la hora de exhalar en
realidad exhalar es tan importante como
inhalar verdad y si no puedes hacer
alguno de estos dos procesos en realidad
es un proceso muy muy muy terrible y
esta persona va a empezar a experimentar
una sensación de falta de aliento o
falta de aire que de hecho podríamos
escribirlo aquí falta de aire muy bien
sin embargo muchas personas para este
tipo de situaciones tienen algo que se
le conoce como inhaladores de rescate
muy bien tienen inhaladores de rescate
que cuando sienten esta sensación que no
pueden respirar pueden liberar cierto
tipo de fármacos o medicinas
urgencia para abrir las vías aéreas y es
muy importante para para las personas
que tienen asma no solo para que puedan
respirar sino para que puedan ayudarles
con el pánico y la incomodidad de no
poder respirar finalmente nada más de la
de la observación que hemos tenido el
asma parece estar relacionado con otras
dos enfermedades con otras dos
enfermedades la primera de ellas es
extrema verdad el eczema es una
enfermedad de la piel en donde tenemos
muchas zonas digamos muy secas de piel
que nuevamente pueden arder verdad y
tienen un color rojo intenso o pueden
ser simplemente secas así que es una
enfermedad de la piel y la tercera es
cuando tenemos alergias muy bien o
algunas personas lo llaman digamos
rinitis alérgica y estas tres cosas
estas tres cosas parecen estar
relacionadas entre sí es decir una
persona que presenta asma es muy
probable que presenten las otras dos muy
bien y eso es particularmente
común en los niños muy bien todavía no
sabemos por qué todavía se están
estudiando este tipo de relaciones que
existen entre estos tres digamos
padecimientos pero especialmente son son
muy relacionados en niños ahora todo
esto fue un súper resumen de cómo se ve
el asma qué es lo que es el asma y
algunas palabras clave que hay que
recordar es que hay una constricción en
las vías aéreas en las pequeñas vías
aéreas verdad que causa una reducción
del digamos de la respiración verdad y
suena como sibilancias en un
estetoscopio